welcome to the together at home series
put on by a global citizen and the World
Health Organization we're gonna sing you
a few songs today we are going to sing a
few songs today because social
distancing doesn't have to be boring no
it doesn't this is a crazy time and
we're all gonna come out of this
together we're gonna pull through and
we're gonna try and connect and make
each other smile
[Music]
this feels like falling in any
[Music]
with me Maddie's doing tons of hot
baking puzzle just doing big Harry
Potter houses are you in great question
phenomenal question I really what house
do you think I'm in be honest so I think
you I think you're a Gryffindor really
yeah I do
that is the nice thing nervous I drove
oh yeah family yeah I think you're in
Gryffindor - I actually definitely think
you're a Gryffindor I mean that from the
bottom my heart this is not a joke I
don't think I'm gonna I mean I want to
be you sue me back - easy
my heart is in Havana
I would just like to say that I'm hype
it up too much because I don't wanna
like it without okay well I don't think
you will
he's been working on because I saw a
comment saying John tell us about new
music I've heard some stuff and it's
pretty magical and I'll just say that
it's pretty magic Oh working on some
music trying to make some magic
yep favorite character of Harry Potter
yes sir no Luna love navel I'm gonna
love good thank you just wrong word no
kill me yeah look no one thinks here the
biggest you know I kissed her last night
and she is she contagious but it's not
in my bio doesn't mean that I'm not a
fan like I'm a fan I just don't know as
much my favorite Hagrid is my favorite
to be honest with you guys I was a
little bit more obsessed with the Game
of Thrones series then Harry Potter but
I also loved Harry Potter thank you guys
World Health Organization go to global
citizen org slash coronavirus please go
on there and forego figure out what you
can do to lend a hand and lend your
voice and stay safe everybody we love
you
love you